how's it going good citizens of the
reject Nation we are back I am back it
is 2023 and we are gonna watch Justice
League War because of how much we
enjoyed Flashpoint and how much you seem
to enjoy us enjoying that movie we read
the comments and the comments seem to
say hey this is a whole series you know
what's next Justice League War and we're
like you know I like a good series and
maybe we'll watch even more of them if
you hit that subscription Bell so you
can get notified if we do in fact watch
from the program for them but hit that
likes we know to watch more of them how
you doing Greg
I was just thinking
Greg that was for you how you doing John
I am terrific I'm ready to step over to
the dark side
because it started a dark universe and
we're going to some sort of War I'm
better I can hear more than I've been
able to hear since Thanksgiving uh I am
propped up on all sorts of like energy
and more energy to come now speaking of
more energy if you want to watch this
full thing synced up with more energy
than you can imagine become a sexy
reject by becoming a patron and you can
watch this whole shebang because we're
watching on HBO Max that's really
accessible so you just line it up sync
it up press play whole ship bang I think
we are ready hit that like leave a
comment let's go to war
[Music]
is this the mysterious Batman who's been
spotted in Gotham
whoa that stands to reason I mean I buy
it
[Music]
what is happening going somewhere buddy
all right you want to dance let's dance
he does have a Frank Miller Batman shape
to him
Green Dragon Lantern your move precious
no no don't oh
nice it's an elevator these movies can
be so good make a Green Lantern movie
good What's it gonna cost me you're
welcome lady
come here
now I ain't falling for that Hal Jordan
knows better
food
high-tech armor huh
you're gonna have to do better than that
oh
damn like a skip Stone okay that was
better
thank you
real Batman what were you doing at the
Docks I want answers
these anime movies do not mess around
they just go
Green Lantern Express so badass in this
take your glow stick and go home
Gotham's mine
[Music]
no see this entire space sector is my
beat
[Laughter]
love the imagination of these things so
good Witnesses spotted this thing trying
to plant some kind of bomb downtown when
the cops confronted it it spewed fire
from its mouth Green Lantern can do
anything except shut up apparently wow
someone forgot to take their True Blood
tonight ah topical I don't have HBO
it's been canceled
oh crap that's a bomb and he just armed
him wait oh yeah
[Laughter]
it's a nice tribute to Batman Forever
it doesn't scan like a bomb more like an
alien computer like the guy in
Metropolis Superman his power levels are
not gonna be a problem for me
it's broadcasting some kind of signal
and we've tracked similar signals
emitting from coast city Gotham and
Metropolis
then it's talking to someone it's trying
to create some kind of unity any further
data on the device
I'll catch up with you later Dr Stoner
the safe just calm flash over the phone
like yeah I'm like I don't feel like
that phone is safe
come on man be a dad don't let him
become cyborg you're messing up
come on
and one for your grandson what
you are not silent yourself go out on a
limb
[Music]
a man
[Applause]
next up Nationals Sports and hard making
some plays yay
I don't know you kid dad dude on my dad
these freaks cost America
who's gonna pay for that us regular
people that's who I know what channel
news he watches that's Grim what is your
problem with me you swing that sword
with a smile and you scare normal people
and you dress like all
wow my guy
Jesus the lasso compels you now tell us
your truth
I cross-dress in a Wonder Woman outfit
it makes me feel powerful
live for truth buddy come on we don't
King shave in this house no not at all
Embrace Your Truth yeah Diana gets it
through this touchdown pass like 4
. doesn't matter if there's not someone
on the other end to make the catch must
be nice to trust someone else that much
just wish I could trust my dad I should
go nice meeting you Victory tell your
dad he's got some great seats yeah I
will oh I think he would love to know
this cold Asher Angel where's my
[Laughter]
that's close I've been tracking his
flight path
on what your own satellite
I love this Batman they're great do they
get paired up a lot I love them together
when they do it's always great I'm
liking it this is a good move first one
to the building is
I really hate that guy
nah you learn to love him
no offense
let's get in the way
Superman's ass TMZ's got the video
topical I'm a lawyer
those are Superman laser oh no
right through the cell
so
what can you do
interesting the creature that attacked
me had one of those boxes you have
all right now let's start if I would
actually go like he's just pushing
forward this is great
like there's no reluctance round two
flyboy
Lantern no
wow
he's pissed off we have to talk to him
yeah use your words boys should have
started there maybe I don't know
you bruised but you don't kill dude
Clark
that's cool
hahaha
Bruce Wayne oh who the hell is Bruce Lee
this is great
oh yeah
yeah we are in danger of losing the
element of surprise my Lord I humbly ask
that you move up your timetable Let The
Invasion begin
oh wow did we get Granny Darkness what's
happening we are witnessing the birth of
a new race of superhumans beings who can
fly tear through buildings and outrun
race cars they will make what you can do
obsolete wow World throwing a football
is a joke wow father of the year you're
never gonna go to one of my games are
you
no wow
what's happening we can talk about this
later the times that you've left I don't
know I'm not really gonna talk yeah
that's kind of that's it you said no you
just cut directly to the chase you might
be staring down the barrel of a
full-scale Invasion you're paranoid
let's just crack it open and see what
happens
sure without any idea what's inside
that is idiotic
I'll show you idiotic
oh
I'm trying to lock in on the signal now
this thing is more important to you than
your own song
oh you've done it it's gonna blow
uh oh
oh cool
Mobile Suit Lantern exactly
Gundam Lantern
[Music]
oh
ouch
we need to get out of here now which way
we have to get him into the Red Room to
turn him into a sexy spy it's inevitable
for the first time I won't leave you
Dad yes Victor I'm here
it's not gonna be easy but ah it's
eating him from the inside out he's
going into cardiac arrest it's racing up
his spinal cord
[Music]
even animated that hurt sound design
I've taken apart and rebuilt most of it
it can save my son's life it has to
no
he's in pain I'm it would seem
[Music]
s going the other way oh I didn't notice
that that's cool yeah
recalibrating memory
what's happening
stay calm son
better be an important phone call
s
it's kovic
whoa
offensive mode activated
blue 42 starts
foreign
[Music]
I was wondering how they're gonna chip
away at it that's cool I mean I feel bad
for him but yeah but it's a great detail
[Music]
[Music]
as quick as I could
what noise Cannon enabled whoa
[Music]
it's a good Discovery after all them
yeah
that's how you fight Batman
[Music]
nice there's too many of them just to
Barrel through yes
oh that's a Superman
wow
that's it smile for me wow
yeah
swing away hey
[Music]
sweet oh it looks just like a McGinnis
drawing that's dope
over cautious huh we'll be fine
[Music]
[Laughter]
I need eyes
wow
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah Diana she got that meeting after
all Wonder Woman
goodness yes
[Music]
oh yeah but now you're on that plane
just uh oh
sweet shot yeah some Iron Man 3 action
yeah what's happened to me your mind is
now a quantum computer Sun there's
buzzing in my ears
make it stop oh
half man half machine you had to make it
just another one of your experiments
don't you hear the buzzing
oh well thick
I empathize you know what I think I am
needed downtown
clearly need to talk so
commencing Paradigm and indoctrination
download initiated whoa
translating command locate inhabitable
worlds
oh werewolf by night
we've only just met you
oh no thank you Clockwork Dark Side
didn't need that at all
repurpose organic materials
para demon
[Music]
oh
dude
always too soon Hal looks like you could
use a hand
flash my boy great to see you
oh yeah and that's Batman
's real yeah he's over there
[Laughter]
favorite line it's over there it's not
for a delivery get ready here they come
hi
Boogie hi
incoming no
[Music]
I can vouch for that he was at Star Labs
oh thank God Barry
hey there what's up Shazam I'm with him
didn't turn back right yeah
you have to shout it
I've talked to their technology they're
terraforming the Earth how do you figure
well for one thing
the water's on fire
oh no oh that's bad
they're very ominous
they're all Sauron eyes
this isn't an isolated incident either
it's happening across the world we're
too late
he's here
oh no yeah
Omega beams Green Lanterns got this
dude
that's a dead Lantern
is that your boyfriend no
cool watch this
Blackheart the Death Eater or whatever
your World of Warcraft name is
wait no
no oh boy
we're gonna have to move fast not a
problem for me
yeah
Flash and Superman are kind of racing
right now yeah they got a little moment
flash is winning as he should
oh smart
never had to catch my breath before
[Laughter]
oh no oh a full skeleton there and we
saw the inside of Kal-El finally the
Kryptonian is ours Master will be
pleased we flew off with him I saw it
they took Superman
I'll get him Lantern dude Lantern
please my name is Bruce Wayne when I was
10 my parents were murdered in front of
my eyes spent my life trying to fight
the same sort of criminals that took
them from me this is different if this
isn't about me you're telling me this
why we won't win without our big gun
where the hell are you going
I'm going to get Superman
cool
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
prepare a demon in the service of a dark
side does that guy decide I assume but
I've never seen him look like bizarroy
it's just a dark side said so once we
have our champion
he will seize the other supers and bring
them as well
Clockwork Kryptonian nope nope nope nope
get him out of there his showboating is
gonna ruin the entire plan
oh great now I'm Batman
foreign
wouldn't you
dude
come out as a team as a team
nice
damn
[Music]
well now it's all blown up hopefully
you're good there
foreign
sludge blood dark side
we only got one more eye
come on Justice League
foreign
's weakness kidneys
sweet
[Music]
flash take out the other eye
come on
yeah I need this to save the world
thanks for your help
I love his delivery too he's always like
talking a little fast Flash is solid
flashlight
[Laughter]
[Music]
the world needs Clark Kent the world
needs his journalism Intrepid reporter
both eyeballs blown out and he's still
stands
we do
try and send him home
with a note to his mama bad boy they're
creating portals boom tubes I just have
to speak their language
I didn't understand it
let's do this video Network
too many pop-ups
ad blocker ad blocker
oh no oh
I guess it's good the void peers back
into you
oh cool oh nice effect
[Music]
damn that's rad
that's actually pretty scary
blind and just sudden around oh
[ __ ] whoa
I don't care
nice
[Music]
yeah nice yes
unable to connect damn it dude
oh
that was awesome
oh
good fall great call
[Music]
come on
[Music]
closure
yeah
nice don't tell him okay it's none of
their freaking business it'll be our
secret I always said
[Laughter]
nice job kid
where'd Shazam go he took off he said he
had a hot date right who'd go out with
that immature Hot Head
human victims let me just get this baby
to Boom for me one more time
yeah oh I love the catcher's mitts we
should leave before they blame us again
oh
all done
thanks for not talking about the other
thing don't sweat it and thanks for
seeing me in here
oh you're the bomb Victory I know I know
you keep reminding me victory victory
what if something like this should
happen again please what could possibly
happen that said oh no I'm very pleased
to introduce to you
do you guys have a name
yes we do you can call us the super
seven oh no
[Laughter]
you don't like it how about just the
seven yeah I think that works out well
this type of team this dynamic it's a
nice little subversion though they dance
around the word League yeah yeah
so the Jeff John Jim Lee so like new 52
I think this is what this is based off
of I I wasn't reading a lot of DC the
new 52 era I think this is based on but
it's like really different I was gonna
ask are the the characterizations seemed
a bit more like spunkified almost yeah
it's definitely like a a little Sean
Aston Michelle Monaghan huh Shamar Moore
Alan Tudyk is not who I would expect it
as Superman damn all right D Bradley
Baker Ian cruffled Mr Fantastic was
Thomas Morrow ah Mercer hey not bad
that's awesome and we know there there's
a post credits we'll probably you know
chitty chat a little bit but we will get
to the post credits scene so stay tuned
for whatever if you're all synced up
whatever version you guys are watching
yeah but yeah like looking at the
characterizations like I really enjoyed
them but I wasn't quite expecting it
definitely isn't like and and you know
every Arc every uh like there's a reason
the crisis has happened like the DC
Universe reboots itself like really
often so when the crisis has happened
like it's a new universe
um some of them I like some I don't
um personally like just personally and
this is gonna people are gonna be mad in
the comments but I I didn't enjoy about
half and I didn't enjoy half
oh what's the next threat I was
wondering where Aquaman's been this
whole time
literally like spiers in the sea I'm
like
oh oh [ __ ] Master the surface dwellers
have killed our King this is an act of
war and they will pay
oh there's our next threat oh damn
fighting the sea got some Ocean Master
shenanigans
uh what so you're I mean more aware of
the movie side than the than the comic
side what did you think of the
characterizations I mean I really I I
enjoyed the
I enjoyed them for being a little bit
off the beaten path yeah but not
extremely so but at the same time I was
aware throughout that at least some of
the characterizations were a bit just a
bit different than especially like
Superman and Wonder Woman were a bit
different than what I associate with
classic yeah I don't have as great of a
Hal Jordan reference point although I
remember people saying that Ryan
Reynolds was like a bit too snarky for
Hal Jordan and that's the thing for me
is like Hal Jordan isn't Kyle Rayner or
Guy Gardner so those are two other
lanterns yeah and and like I Kyle Rainer
is my favorite Lantern because he's all
about creativity because he makes more
ornate crazy things like with his
Lantern power and they leaned that way
with some of the snark and his power use
but Guy Gardner is kind of a dick and
they kind of added that to him too so
this hell felt like three of the
different lanterns and that made him
kind of feel like diluted because he was
he was three of them like to me that
makes so like I didn't really like
identify with this how like it doesn't
feel like hell to me but it's more
interesting than some of the takes on
hell because he's very stoic and a
little bit more rigid in some takes but
like to me that wasn't really how Jordan
um but the Wonder Woman thing like I did
not like this one like that I didn't
mind Green Lantern but Wonder Woman
would never say like it's good to be
back in the heat of War like she also
wouldn't threaten people like she likes
Humanity like she wouldn't go around
like causing problems and she was like
hot-headed and childish and that's not
that childlike is Diana like the scene
on the boat is Diana because she's
learning about the world with open eyes
and an open heart childish is judging
and like swinging a sword around and
being immature like there's a big
difference yeah and obviously you're
much more an expert than I but I
associate Diana with being a bit more
poised and yeah having a bit more
awareness of everyone around and
concerned and yeah just like being I
think that's a great distinction
childlike versus childish she's she's
Regal but childlike this was arrogant
and like a despot like like you know she
didn't she didn't like I wouldn't want
to have a meeting with the mascara if
this was their Regent like it just felt
very hot-headed yeah yeah I can I can
get on board with that it's like I found
it using as uh I did enjoy it as a take
and I thought that the type of character
can Merit this but at the same time it
was perhaps the most uh sort of not
distracting but noticeable departure for
me so that was pretty distracting for me
yeah I was like I'm enjoying this I'm
amused by this but also I could see how
this isn't necessarily definitive uh and
could you know yeah potentially betray
some of the spirit of the character when
like what I thought was the voice acting
was good work but then the lines weren't
the character so like I I very much
noticed it as soon as she showed up I
was like oh this voice works fantastic
it feels powerful it sounds like what I
think Diana would sound like I'm a huge
Michelle Monaghan fan didn't realize it
was her until the end and then I was
like oh that tracks yeah but I think the
portrayal of her acting wise could have
been great but the the writing and the
and the way they wrote the character
like none of that's Diana like there
wasn't a single scene that I was like
that's that's Wonder Woman Like That
quintessential yeah and like then
Superman he's so so for me Green
Lantern's like half and half and
Superman's like half and half and Wonder
Woman's completely wrong to me but again
this different take but this almost felt
like an else world this felt more like
an other world Batman is perfect Batman
spot on I loved Batman and this is the
Batman you need in like when James Gunn
rewrites the universe Pattinson should
stay over there in my opinion and a
Batman like this should be the one that
interacts with these characters yeah a
more seasoned Batman and a Batman who
has been doing this long enough to have
like a mild humor about it yeah there's
got to be a little bit of like
tongue-in-cheek like I'm a guy in a bat
suit whereas the Reeves universe that's
not what the character is so you you
won't like that won't work in a comedic
I'm aware of how weird this is the way
yeah and I I just feel like Superman
like there's something about some
creators that just want to make Superman
evil like I don't know what it is like
they just like he's always like on the
edge and so like when he killed that
dude I'm like well that's just one step
away away from snapping zod's like
everyone just wants to homelander them
and the reason homelander works is
because it is so opposite like the
reason homelander like it's reacting to
yeah so if if he's even 10 closer to
homelander it negates both of them sure
I did have that thought it's another
Wonder Woman moment but I did have that
thought in the plane of like thank God
this Wonder Woman is like at least on
the good side of this fight otherwise
this could turn into a boy's situation
and yeah this this very much felt like
they those two characters could turn and
I don't think that's the characters like
he doesn't go you know arrogantly you
know you're welcome to Batman like
Batman is snarky but like Superman
doesn't rub it in people's faces that he
has more Powers that's why he's super is
because he's not
proud of his abilities he has a
responsibility yeah yeah I can I can
definitely see where you're coming from
with that and and it didn't bother me
but but like I said it was certainly
noticeable like I enjoyed like for me I
enjoyed this front to back oh I had a
fun time but I had to make an US World
else World up here yeah and then that
was the thing is is and and we'll get to
you know all the the juicy plot stuff
but that was the thing coming out of the
previous movie because everyone's like
oh this this is the next one and I guess
that communicated to me the idea of like
okay this is gonna flow directly
continuation and that one I loved loved
like that was like a Phantasm good I was
I was a little worried because I'm so
excited to watch this whole journey and
like as long as you know people keep
wanting to have us watch these I wanted
to but this felt like Flashpoint to me
was an A plus Phantasm level genre
redefining I'm like overwhelmed and this
I had to reread it as an elseworld and I
and this was more of like a c for me
like not gonna lie like I really I
struggled and maybe it's personal
because we're going through this reboot
of DC and I keep reading about people
that just fundamentally disagree with
who Superman is to me and what worries
me is I'm always worried I'm the one
that's wrong and I know every character
is archetypal every character has
interpretation sure but I have so much
comic book data as well as like reasons
behind why Superman can't be like this
and then I see things like this and I'm
like well this is why these people all
think that's Superman because that's
what people are making so I'm worried if
someone makes something in this vein
it's it's falling down that same problem
and again what if I'm wrong what if this
is Superman yeah and I feel like the
animated movies lend more Credence to
the idea that something would be
presenting itself as comic book
authenticity exactly like that more so
than the automatic I think handicap you
give a live-action movie of like well
they're gonna change that they have to
adapt it's a movie yeah yeah and I mean
this was this was cool in in a way to
you know like we just had the Snyder cut
and we've had you know lots of
inspiration come out out of this story
for you know the live-action DC movies
we've seen recently and so it was really
cool to watch the counterparts in this
iteration and and like I said yeah in
terms of performances and
characterizations I really enjoyed
watching everyone together yeah the last
fight dude like I kept saying during
like that was Jackie Chan yeah like they
did the thing where it's like why aren't
they all attacking ones oh they are dark
side's that good but the way they
choreographed that fight like dark side
was perfect okay positives Dark Side uh
I I really enjoyed flash yeah uh I
really enjoyed Shazam I think they did a
great job with Billy and Shazam Shazam
and Cyborg both yeah both as individuals
and together I really like and they gave
them time I really enjoyed that this
gave cyborg time cyborg is still the
heart it was still yeah literally
because that is one thing about about
this that did surprise me is is like I
said I I very much enjoyed watching and
I had a blast but given what a
significant Arc it is what a significant
villain and story it is it
it's funny looking at Flashpoint Paradox
that gets straight to the point and it
doesn't feel like it's short or anything
like that or like it's lacking in any
substantial element whereas this does
get kind of right to the point and you
pretty much just watch them deal with
yeah it almost feels like a big act 3
movie because we don't meet Bruce Wayne
really we have a reveal we have a
conversation we never meet Clark yeah
and there's certain things that are like
the the beauty of superheroes is they
have to balance their other lives and if
you don't have their other lives come to
play at all you notice it yeah like Hal
Jordan's got four seconds on screen but
he's just out of his like there's no
human element and that's literally just
to like clarify for us in the back like
okay it's house
and then Batman to reference it later
yeah so like I I just feel like uh we
didn't get the people behind the heroes
in this yeah I liked the the like ending
idea of you know touching on like the
gods it's nice to be among a Pantheon
again and sort of directly checking who
some of these Inspirations are but yeah
I guess I you know in my armchair
criticism I could have used yeah just
maybe a little more like this is a tight
you know 80 minutes or so I I could have
you know I would have gladly sat for
another 10 or 15 to get yeah a little
more of the life of the characters
because two if it was just directly
feeding out of the last movie and like
voice casting aside like that's one
thing but yeah yeah just like the
overall characterizations felt like I
was watching a new movie with a new set
of interpretations and so yeah you don't
have the previous movie then to fall
back on whereas at the start you kind of
feel like maybe you could uh because
yeah and like Flashpoint Paradox you
still do get at least a little bit of
the personal side of things and
especially through Barry Allen obviously
because of how personal that story is
but yeah like as as just a swath of of
sort of action and you know characters
all pointed towards a single convergence
Point like yeah I thought it was
thrilling and fun and well directed but
yeah I mean not as big of a slam dunk
for me as under the Red Hood and as uh
and his Flashpoint Paradox so I enjoyed
the action I enjoyed like you said the
the arrow the points that all coming
together and I liked the characters we
did have time with like we got to meet
Victor and Cyborg so he was a highlight
we got to meet Barry and Flash he was a
highlight we got we didn't get Bruce but
we got such a good Batman I was really
impressed with this Batman because I
I've said and it's gotten me yelled at
by all sorts of DC fans that the Batman
Dynamic has to be difference between uh
the the Matt Reeves Batman which I
mentioned earlier and Bruce Wayne versus
Batman Batman's effectively three
characters there's Batman there's the
public Bruce Wayne and there's the
private Bruce Wayne which is why I'm
such a fan of what Christian Bale did
because sure he played three characters
he's not playing two he's playing three
so I really like that we have those
three characters in uh the comic books
but we don't have those in the Matt
Reeves movie because they he hasn't
developed his third character yet yeah
he doesn't even care about that right
now yeah he doesn't like Bruce Wayne
doesn't and that was lot of people's
criticism with the Matt Reeves Batman
was Bruce Wayne was barely in it and I
was like that's the point is is he is
Batman the mask is Bruce but Bruce
hasn't developed the mask yet so we just
developed so badly not to be bruised so
why would he develop the Playboy Persona
when he doesn't even care about the
shell of Bruce so this is a more Dynamic
way to make the Batman here work with
these gods and realize how ridiculous
this job is but that humor is so
important so they nailed the humor they
nailed the way he fights they nailed the
smarts and all those things so I loved
this Batman like there's a lot of
positives like if this was a Batman
story that had these characters as
elswirls that he's interacting with and
he's like why is Diana so weird yeah I'd
love that like that all worked for me
and Billy Batson like I I thought the
stealing of the the Jersey was genius
like I really enjoyed their Dynamic a
lot uh and then the like the team up at
the end like a lot works for me I don't
want to I don't want to sound negative
but to me it was like we just got out of
I think two of the best animated movies
ever yeah so I'm really excited for the
next one because because you were saying
like the next one like a lot of people
like and leading into this next series
so um yeah I dug it but I am excited for
the next one more yeah and I didn't even
realize that's uh that's the thing is
it's I I'm hoping to hone my ear for the
voices because each time we come into
this I'm like okay who is and I feel
like I'm gonna miss an anvil and I get
to the end credits and be like oh of
course but uh freaking Matt O'Mara like
he's got the Dual cred because I know
him from Agents of Shield and the MC
kind of you and now it's over and now
doing Batman here like I loved his take
on the character yeah I really liked his
Batman I I don't know that actor so I'll
look him up that is a solid Batman yeah
and Michelle monaghan's Wonder Woman is
probably my favorite oh sure well and I
hope to hear I hope she does more Wonder
Woman because it would be nice to you
know hearing especially that perspective
and again kind of having her be one of
the more obvious tone-shifted characters
I would love to hear Michelle monaghan's
take on a more classic Wonder Woman and
two with Superman it does I I have
started to very much sort of cherish and
and appreciate when I find an
interpretation that does seem like it it
is whoever's writing it isn't feeling
encumbered by the tenets of the
character well that's what's so hard is
he's a lot like Captain America where
it's like on paper how do you make this
guy interesting like how do you make
this character that's why I was so
impressed Chris Evans take because he
made a very impossible character
fascinating then Winter Soldier leveled
it up to a 20. but Superman is I think
one of the hardest characters to write
and that's why there's so few comic runs
I'd recommend and that's why I always
wonder if I'm wrong because they're so
you know I mean he's been around for 70
years I'm like I like these 30 like
they're so funny that's still a lot no
I'm not even saying 30 years like 30
runs like like that's still a lot still
a lot that's fair but like in the that
was here I was over here like what if
five or six there's five issues kid this
is Superman this is the only good guys
uh I know I'm in the minority here but
one issue with Superman really gets them
uh but yeah it's hard to uh it's hard to
feel like you know what the character is
when a lot of people do see him more
aggressively and I just feel like that's
fundamentally not how he's perceived if
that's Superman but I'm curious what the
next film's interpretation especially of
these two that I'm flummoxed by I'm
really excited to see more cyborg now
that he gets through the heart with some
screen time yeah I wanted more flash I
get why we got limited time because they
were sharing with Barry
um Shazam being part of the Justice
League makes me so happy because if we
don't get to see that very much and now
Aquaman it looks like with that post
credit scene yeah I'm really excited for
the next one and and okay and the post
credit scene the king is dead that's not
Aquaman himself no it must be
um like I was like where's Aquaman this
feels like someone's missing we got to
the end and then I was like oh yeah when
when they had yeah like right when that
Big C Spire was disappearing when they
had won I was like oh yeah like she's
got to be going wild in the oceans right
they dropped a lot of stuff and those
numbers Cuts there we never acknowledge
Aquaman and he's like one of the
quintessential Justice League it's not a
complaint and obviously they did it for
a reason but but yeah I'm like where
where's Aqua Mission it's like a thing
we missed man and I'm curious which take
he is sure and like this seems to be a
going universe so what's he gonna be
like yeah and and and two if the next
take even you know is consistent with
these things yeah does this continue uh
audience let us know which of these
characters you feel like are the most
accurate to your interpretation like I
said archetypal let us know uh which of
these movies you enjoy the most let us
know if you feel like we were spot on or
if you're gonna yell at me about my
thoughts on Superman and Wonder Woman
because it's coming uh but please please
please no matter what do comment do like
do subscribe hit that notification Bell
we are gonna do more of these but we
need you to like subscribe share if you
want to see more of these because that's
how the internet works so please do all
of that and uh patrons hope you enjoyed
your sink to sync Line to Line watching
it with us in HBO Max right John I love
doing this week man I love doing this
with you real fun I'm excited from trees
I am too oh 2023 hanging out dude I'm
looking forward to it I love that you
guys are looking for it seems like
everyone's been pretty popular I was I
actually read the comments didn't didn't
break me didn't cry once not nope not
even a little bit I didn't have to well
dude in the spirit of love let's end
this video off with a with a patron of
the day shout out
Lance door you're the Superman of this
Channel and you know what you would be
the iconic definitive interpretation
you're a good dude you're a stand-up
dude but you know how to get stuff done
does Superman ever quip uh like he ever
he doesn't quip in the traditional sense
but he'll say something that is so like
Earnest and sincere it comes across as
it does that make sense like he'll say
something and you're like oh where that
it's funny but he might not even realize
it or everyone else is like if that's so
Superman like that kind of Quip dude
that's that's the Lance door humor that
I feel like you would have you would
show up kick open a door douse a fire
say something kind to the kid and then
the kid's like hey you got jokes Lance
doors yes that's I guess that's what I'm
hoping in 2023 get funnier Lance come on
you got a great name Lance that's all I
know about you yeah good name Lance real
strong yeah the two syllables but like
with them oomph there like Lance door
yeah he's got some yeah if a guy kicked
down a door and was like Lance doors I
don't know why it's always a door like
an 80s action now he's in these action
started my mind dude yeah yeah tear
those sleeves off and you know cover
yourself with some baby oil oil off
Lance door or Lambo makeup proud of you
love you buddy hope your 2023 is off to
a good start and we'll see you next
month we'll see you for the next one of
these animated movies we're excited
about and trailers and stuff you know
you know what you're doing here you're
an hour and a half into a video you know
you know where you're at all right bye
rejects I love you
[Music]